all right anastasia yeah anastasia where
did you grow up where are you from
originally i'm originally from russia
smallwood garzava oh really yes and uh
you came to the united states when um i
was nine
so your parents moved here um i don't
have parents
who raised you i actually grew up in an
orphanage in russia
and um got adopted from russia out here
of the fall of the communism in the
united states so i was the first group
of kids to get rescued from russia kind
of adopted
and i came out with the family that
actually gave me back up for adoption
because they really only wanted the tax
write-off and to look good for the you
know their family and people around them
that they adopted russian kids
literally they admitted it to the courts
when they gave me back up so you went to
another family i stayed up for foster
care
for the rest of my
childhood
so from ages what to what you had no
parents uh
really
i mean i was with the year with the
family
yeah i
don't even really count it so you grew
up with our parents basically yeah never
had family how do you think the
childhood you had with no parents
has affected you as an adult
it's damaged a lot i'm sure of me if i
can't have i can't be in a relationship
whatsoever you feel me because i mean
the biggest thing about you know life is
that when you're newborn you tell me
you're supposed to be held
loved nurtured and cared you know and
that's something i never had
so i was
straight from the beginning i was just
orphanage you know so there's like 300
kids in there you feel me poverty you
probably never saw
never seen a loving loving relationship
yeah never felt it never was held even
picked up as a baby so
for me it just it blocks it for me a lot
so like i can't show love compared to
somebody else
can usually show it because like i still
have that i have a coldness and like
yeah they say they call it my cold heart
because i i just have a blockage they
only i can own love so far
you know so it gives me
that little block in my life that i
can't trust nobody i can't do nothing
like you feel like you were ever loved
by anyone
no
how old are you
i'm about to be 30.
yep you went through school
yep
graduated high school i did actually i
graduated early
did you what part of the us were you in
um i actually did foster care most of my
time in utah out of all places
when i came from america though
i came to actually north carolina
and that's where like
it was also the craziest part of my life
that people don't understand is that
it was racist out there
in north carolina where i came from
wilson
so i didn't know the language
english you told me i only knew russian
and i'm watching
the whole
environment around me
and i was actually treated worse than
the blacks of that neighborhood in the
community out there because you're
russian because i yeah i came from
russia and i'm communism and i was like
as alien
to them
they've shunned me they
they like spoke just disrespected me you
feel me i was locked in my room kind of
stuff i was
i was just like a
disgrace to the world
you know and
could any of that have been
imagined by you
no i mean i was literally like
it was just like
for me i was i didn't understand the
language english at all at this point
and i'm just watching the the kids at
the at in the town we sat in the black
back of the classroom the blacks did at
this time still to this day kind of
stuff
and i remember the teacher even saying
that
the reason why their test scores were
down were because of the
um
[ __ ] or whatever are um were the
population of the group of the school
and that's why their test scores were
down and stuff like that like
one black family moved down on the
neighborhood and everybody put the
houses up for sale everybody in the
neighborhood
and it was like what i didn't understand
it
and but then i was locked in my room
kind of stuff i was
like made fun of at school and when i
ever got to go to school i wasn't about
to go to school and test spoke english
you know so it was just weird and i
could see this stuff i'm like wait
you're in my skin same skin color why am
i getting treated worse than these
people
you know i mean and i didn't see like
black or whatever i just saw i thought
they were burnt
i've never seen that stuff in russia at
the time you know orphanage so it's just
different for me and then they're the
ones that like you took care of me
brought me in on the you know i mean
they felt they knew where i was coming
from
you know i mean they nurtured me they
old lady used to like give me cookies
and milk you feel me after school
all that kind of stuff so i've been able
to just click more with that side wow
and you've been living on the streets
for how long um since i graduated
actually high school
um and went to college i was 16 when i
graduated high school
um honorables
and stuff like that i beat the system
i figured out that the only way to get
out of foster care was to get
emancipated and to graduate with a high
school diploma
and so that's what i did really really
fast because i got actually a sports
scholarship
to utah valley university at the same
time my sport um basketball and
volleyball
i was second street point guard
and stuff like that so i'm with matt to
that
and um i was 18 19.
yes 18 19 middle to
gear kind of stuff that i actually hurt
my knee
playing in college
hurt my knee and i couldn't play no more
and that was like my main thing and then
foster care because i still wasn't
emancipated until you're 18. so
they still had me like in the foster
care system per se a little bit so they
refused to take me to school
because
and they refuse for the surgery
that i'd need for my knee you know i
mean
and so they held me back
and i couldn't go finish my college my
whole
semester so made a no call like no show
whatever
so they i kind of got kicked out of my
own school and where'd you go after that
and after that i literally
ended up in california with my friend
and
introduced the streets
is that where drugs started for you uh
drugs registered for me actually in
foster care
um one of my foster families actually
showed me
methamphetamine
um they too he took me to like a
old apartment building filming no lights
in it whatever and like
a lot of mexicans all in this one
apartment and like pipes are getting
passed around the smoke everywhere
and that's where i learned about
meth and stuff of that and i found out
that if i smoke meth actually at the
time i could stay up i could protect
myself for stuff that was happening in
the foster home and take care of the
other girls while they were sleeping
just because stuff kept on happening so
was there abuse going on in the foster
system oh yeah for sure anything that
you could think of imaginable happen to
me in foster care for sure
i got raped to just
mistreated completely to being a slave
to actually got kidnapped
for a little bit of time
they probably started at a very early
age
yeah yeah i was like kidnapped at 12
literally from with some mexicans
there's nine of us girls
in a basement kind of stuff about to be
sex trade um whatever but
yeah so i went through a lot
boarding school all girls boarding
school 300 girls all delinquents from
everywhere
so that opened up my whole life to a lot
of things too
so you've been supporting yourself how
um i used to do drugs
um
i did that for a couple years for sure
and then while i was dealing drugs
actually um i got introduced to a lot of
pimps
and um other people in the game who say
you know officer poverty
in california
you know right up there valley and um
they were buying drugs off me for their
girls and they keep on with telling me
like oh look how good you look you can
make money like this look at my girls
look you feel me back then they took
care of the girls back then you feel not
like now but um
they uh he they just kept on you know
spitting my ear and then um i actually
got
um a case on me um
in 2013
for drugs yeah for drugs transportation
like
a lot of stuff and they did it to your
joint suspension on me so like when i
did that i'm done i'm cool i'll leave i
left california into arizona
but um
that is where i really started
but then
like i said in arizona
i kind of squared up you know how to
pretend i'm all good and i should end up
having my son out there oh you have a
son my first kid how many kids do you
have i got three all together and you're
right two boys and a girl you raise them
um my sons my first one is the only one
i raised
for at least a couple years
and the kids are aware now
well my first son's with his sister with
his aunt or whatever
my second son with the family he got
adopted
and my daughter is also adopted just
barely
yep
so
yeah it's changed a lot of me too
made me
way different person
yeah
what emotions do you go through after
all this
uh
i try to go through another day
you know what i mean because every day i
just like
i don't think about it i literally don't
no more
do the drugs help you deal yeah
that's the only reason why i use drugs
you know just so i don't have to think
about
all everything you know me because i
actually have bad anxiety
anyways
i have bad anxiety
like i in bad depression whatever ptsd
or trauma
[Music]
because of stuff also like being abused
and
all that kind of [ __ ] so
i just get high
not for sex and on stupid [ __ ] like i
just keep normal keep saying and
be able to work with with the community
and be with everybody
without feeling crazy and
just depressed bishop so
and your drug is crystal meth yeah
yes
where are you staying currently um right
now
i'm back out here downtown skid row
right there in a freaking little tent
you know but
i don't know
sex work is still your support system
uh
i don't really have
nobody so
every day's a struggle
don't know the government took away my
[ __ ] citizenship actually
and questioned it whatever a couple
years ago
because i got in trouble with the law
whatever and
for some reason they checked my
paperwork whatever and
because of their mishap and mistake
unfortunately it's crazy as hell they
need to
hear this [ __ ] but
they made a mistake when i got adopted
and re-adopted in america whatever from
foster care and the adoption family they
had two identities they made on accident
they didn't find paperwork correctly
because back to back so fast
and so i had two identities in the
system so they started questioning like
all that and then um they try to call my
family my adopted family to see if they
prove to who i am like that they agree
that they brought me from russia all
that kind of [ __ ] they denied
you that they even like knew me or
whatever but
i mean it was crazy because i'm like you
guys are on my birth certificate of
adoption like
but you guys denied me and then russia
they got hold of russia's embassy and
they try to question about like who i am
and
unfortunately which is even crazier the
adopted the orphanage i came from was
fraud
and i don't exist in the system out
there either they can't find no
paperwork on me
but they know of me and my family
which is crazy because my family i guess
my family background in russia
my real bloodline is actually like
russian spy and
like mob kgb mob affiliated guests
whatever
and so like that that's even more like
crazy like
well now i look even crazier messed up
out here in america did you have a an id
or social security number uh i did i
have two apparently in the system oh i
see so like
look me up in the system fingerprint me
and
i'll come up two different two different
same name whatever but just a little bit
off
literally
so i had a social and uh uh alien
do you have friends
do i have friends
not really i mean i just choose not to
because i already
my whole life i already know it's gonna
end per se like any friendship you know
or any kind of
any kind of like thing
with another somebody else is just it's
going to end at some point we're going
to separate you know there's going to be
something that we're not going to see
each other again so you enter the
relationship assuming it's not going to
work yeah i just know it's not going to
last and so like for me
i'm already like i'm always having make
a joke of it all the time like my bag's
always packed you know i mean i i'm
always ready to go and it's
i just already know like
the only the only word
i um i believe or trust is really god's
word because anybody else's word to me
is like it's nothing
you know i mean because you can say
you're going to be there you feel me
you're always going to be there
you care for me or you
you know got my back or whatever but
when push comes to shove
it this shows always differently
you know i mean it just shows people's
true colors and it's never
what it is
so i just built myself a wall already
just accept that
and to just
already be okay with it
because i just block it all
would you describe yourself as
self-destructive
um
i don't know if it i don't know
if that would be the right word i don't
know what it is
like kind of it sounds like you sabotage
relationships yeah i mean i just
because i just yeah given where you came
from it's understandable yeah i just
more of a
yeah i just don't have that trust in in
my own life and feelings to accept
anything more and let it go farther than
anything else have you been
in relationships like that lasted longer
than
a year or anything like that
no
nobody actually been single now for over
a year
are you lonely
huh are you lonely
am i lonely
sometimes
but
it
outweighs
the
the effect of
what happens if i am a new relationship
the fear of yeah just anxiety
all the extra stuff that comes in and
being a relationship and
the extra like
pressure puts on someone you know you'd
rather be single i'd rather be single
ready alone
yep
what do you worry about
um
what are you afraid of
um
myself
because i don't know
personally my own limits
in life you know i mean like
i've always been so quiet though like i
just try and go through life as quietly
as possible without making a disturbance
even though i know
because i hate how
everyone like
always ever since i've known like
looks at me like oh you're gorgeous you
look you're so you know just all the
sexual stuff like
they see on me like it just it gets to
the point where you're just annoying
honestly
i guess like
i always wondered like if
anybody actually would see me for me and
not just because of how it looked
you know
because
my whole life has been like that
from foster family you know the dads
whatever people just in general like
i've always just been like sexible
to people even as a child even as a
child like
it makes me always like it it's super so
just almost annoying that's why i think
nowadays i don't care about sex i don't
feel nothing
i don't
nothing you know i mean it's just a way
to make money it's yes it's my work
that's all it is
you know i mean that's something that
also stops me in a lot of relationships
too because
i just don't i don't feel
like pleasures or whatever i never have
you know and it
again that goes back to my childhood i
guess like not being nurtured and cared
for whatever
i'm liking it's numb to me
do you have any good memories of your
life
um
yeah you know i mean
i just really blocked out a lot of stuff
you know me having your children
like i said i've always just accepted
that something was gonna happen so i
just
didn't let it happen
even that made
like that might be a fun activity you
know i mean i didn't do it because
i knew we had to stop soon you know i
mean we have to end it sometimes and
then
it wouldn't be
fun anymore you know
and i'll lose all the happiness i was
having so do you feel like life is
unfair
or you're you're cursed or anything
something like that sometimes you see me
for sure your life seems pretty like
divine i feel like
i'm stuck
you know just
i can't get past
like a level life per se
and there's always going to be a stump
like if i even if i get like this close
i have to fall back like there's always
something that
happens like
and it's so simple too it's like
[ __ ] that anybody else should be able to
do you know would be like
own their own like apartment or house or
whatever and
you know i mean just be more independent
because they know me have to leave their
own
i still can't get
and it's always like the stupidest
reason why i can't get it like no i
can't get my id
i can't get my documents
i've even tried to order my sister
document whatever
and um
[ __ ] every time it takes a year and a
half to order this document just to
order
like 500
and in that time period russia in united
states gets into some [ __ ] you feel
me hacking or spying or whatever [ __ ]
and they close the borders so you get
denied
and so after you know i mean that's
another year wasted like
it's like it's just like been a struggle
for like five years now just to even
like prove who i am
to the government
just so i can get help and just be
per se like noticed or alive like
i can't [ __ ] get hardly i can't get a
job i can't do nothing i lost my kids
because of that you don't mean i can't
make money correctly you know as a law
by citizen because of a stupid id or
identity in my
so it's hard
because you have to resort back to
obviously
doing being a sex prostitute whatever
escort dancer all this kind of
quiet undergraduate [ __ ]
just didn't survive like i'm not doing
this for drugs i'm not doing this stuff
for anything else for anybody else
nothing i'm just doing this so i can eat
and try to keep a roof over my head
so
just to
wait until hopefully
paperwork is correct
you still have hope of getting your life
together or improving your situation
yeah
yeah with it
at the same time i don't you know
i just don't even try to think about it
anymore you know me i don't expect too
much but i don't expect too little
either you know
i still try a little
for some reason part of me just
constantly it's school
i don't give up
i mean a lot of people always say like
how am i still standing today compared
to
like a lot of people
have already
probably gone insane or whatever by the
time
they're my right now and my age
just because of all the [ __ ] that's
happened to me
but
i'm still somehow like able just to keep
on standing
it could push you forward like another
day
people just say oh it's the russian in
you being you know you're so strong and
impressions are known to be that way you
know you've had to be strong since you
were a child
ever since i can remember
you know me even an orphanage you know i
mean there's like 300 kids and something
orphanage
i was taking care of the kids too the
four babies in the crib
you know i mean
is there anything that you think you
could have done differently in your life
to maybe steer it
in a better direction
it's not really your
fault i mean
yes and no you know what i mean but do
you have any regrets of like i don't
have regrets not really someone said you
were just dealt some terrible hands
i've just been able to
i wish it didn't happen to me you know
me the the life the change of events you
know i mean
that played out you know
but at the same time
it is what it is you know i mean
it's got me to be who i am now
which i'm not also
like not
upset about like i
i wouldn't you know
go back to try to change anything
because it wouldn't even
it wouldn't make me me
it sounds like you you've never been in
love
no
do you have any hope of ever being in
the
no
i've just been able to accept this in my
life you know i mean it took me forever
to because i used to as a kid
fight all the time to be accepted to be
something to somebody
you know and that got me into a lot of
other [ __ ] you know i mean
you know i mean just to be accepted by
somebody and it has it could be anybody
you know me i've given up my money i've
given up everything
even though i knew it was hurting me
i still do it just to try to feel
accepted but then i finally
for some reason
um was able to just like realize that
you know what
i need to quit trying to just be
accepted like
it is what it is like
i need to learn how to accept just
myself
you know i mean so
that's really what
i've had to do what personality trait do
you have that helps you survive
um
i just
just look for the next day like i'm just
leaving one day at a time
you know i mean i just try not to worry
too much you know it's a very dangerous
life you're living
i'm sure you've had bad things happen to
you
oh yeah for sure
but
i can't i wish
i wish i could change it i wish i didn't
have to do it but again
i was dumping my hand i was down you
know
and so i have to make the best of it i
can
and i am strong compared to a lot of
people you know i mean i do
i do know how to like walk into interest
into a room you know and all eyes are on
me and i just am able to hold myself you
know
with more head on my shoulders for
saying you know what i mean i'm not
scared to like say what needs to be said
but it took me a while to get there
you know i mean
to be able to actually like
help somebody know you know i mean or
just to be like i am
you know i am escort and i am i work for
sex you know me for money all that kind
of stuff like i'm able to stay in that
state and say so what
as before i was quiet
but if let's let's say some guy met you
and just thought you were great and
wanted to
bring you into his life and just
give you a better life do you think
you'd sabotage that
i wouldn't even accept it
you wouldn't even allow it to happen i
wouldn't allow it to happen
because
i've just learned in life that
no matter like any human like for them
to give something they they expect
something back
you know i mean it can be good or bad
pros or cons you don't mean any action
there is
done as a human you know so
when it comes to that stuff then it's
like okay well i'll think about it all
quick and fastly in my head like okay
well that's
what that is how
you know take care of me whatever and
just wants to put me on his way or
whatever what does that do what is the
place you want sex you probably what
does he want me to pay you for me like
there's always like that i'm always
gonna like okay what does he want out of
it
you know what i mean and
is this really what he actually cares
you feel me or is he just seeing me
again as a sex officer or just to look
good for somebody else you don't even
believe that unconditional love exists
um
you know i mean because like i said when
i was adopted i was a trophy
you know i mean the front page of the
newspaper i was a i was a money bad
buyout from america america bought me
literally saved me
which is crazy like to think about like
that's all i want to do the first front
page picture in the newspaper and the
tax rate off
that's all i was good for
you know
so it's always been like so what am i
good for you're better off staying in
russia
i mean not even then
i honestly
because orphanage wasn't any better it
was poverty and terrible out there kids
were dying of yellow fever in front of
me
we had our toilets were actually holes
in the in the wall in the [ __ ] floor
it was like hell freezing cold it was
like a warehouse thousand
fed once a day maybe is that why there
are so many russian wives
russian women looking to marry american
men
those are actually honestly those are
they're all married in russia they're
men they're pimps you know me
literally their husbands out there there
is
they're a ruler like girls out there
have still still to this day don't have
a last day
in relation so you're telling me all the
russian mail-order brides are actually
married to somebody back in russia 98 of
them their husbands are people they're
told yeah they're so they come to
america and they get money and they
they told to you know
come to america he feel me and they they
even hook them up a lot of time with the
american that's going to take bring them
from russia
yep
any girls send this money back to russia
um they will they will they can do it
they do it for years
and get their social you feeling get all
like literally will
clear your whole life away
they really like that it's crazy that
people
people a lot of people have actually
experienced you know me but
it's
there's a big percentage of the girls
are like that they're
they really do have somebody behind them
or even a family member
we'll set them up that way
and that's what's crazy because families
out there is like generations and
generations in one household
you know so if their families like that
and it's always been like a tradition in
their family to do this kind of stuff
the next you know first daughter of each
family you know was
sent out here
you know i mean as a money scheme or
ponzi kind of [ __ ] you know i mean and
they like literally train their whole
life
i've seen it like they've trained their
whole life just for this whole act that
they're about to put on
that might cost years
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
um after everything you've been through
shoot
honestly just that
not to
give up or not
to
honestly just expect anything or
expect
anything out of life you know i mean
just to
go with the flow more
that's really the lesson i've learned
because that if you set something like a
goal per se it's going to be not met
in other words
you know you set a goal just for it to
fail fail
for some reason it's just how it is
yeah my my story is my life
i mean i i'm able to accept it i don't
want no pity from nobody i don't want
nothing you know me because
it is what it is i wouldn't want them in
my shoes and i don't want to be yours
you know i mean we all have different
backgrounds so
i can't compare or complain
it won't change
it was fine
i'm so sorry for you
thank you very very much
you